hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back home for honor again
and today we're gonna be talking about
the deficit recap for this week we have
free weekend stuff a warrior training
program revamp champion status really
nice content of the week and other
things to talk about as always like the
video if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I cover the leaks the
information all the stuff for the
informational site of fallen or where
that be new heroes leaks all that type
of good stuff I'm gonna be covering that
on the channel and with that guys let's
get started
first up for Honor's gonna be getting a
free weekend on May 3rd and it's going
to start from May 3rd and end May 6 so
if you have any friends that you want to
introduce them into for honor and
definitely tell them about the free
weekend there's also going to be a
warrior training program and they've had
this the past couple times they've done
free weekends but for anybody that isn't
aware basically to participate a current
game owner that possibly being you and
then a newcomer a person who doesn't own
the game will partner up and play at
least 5 matches during the free weekend
grouping up is a unique way to
experience the world before honor and a
great opportunity to share techniques
once players complete these matches that
will work both earn it two weeks of
revamp champion status which we'll get
into what that actually means on screen
while I was talking you may have seen
some of the time zones that's going
that's when it's going to be live it is
UTC time which is the universal time
zone obviously it's a little bit
different for everybody else so just
kind of work around with your time zone
and where you're located and the
platform that you're on
now this revamp champion status that I
just mentioned is basically champion
status which players are significantly
getting more XP in lieu after every
match completed and has an in-game value
of 8000 steel revamp champion status
benefits include a 40 percent boost of
XP at the end of the game for the player
that is a new feature a 20 cent 20% XP
boost aura for the other players at the
end of the game that is also new and
more event loot which is the last thing
that is new on top of that we're getting
the champion status icon one emblem as
usual more end of match loot and more
Salvage now the first three things I
mentioned they were obviously in the
game already but they're just increasing
it more so say for example I don't know
what the actual value is but let's just
say for example you earn 25% XP at the
end of every game with champion status
now you're earning 40% so basically
you're getting lots more xp for you and
your team and you're getting way more
loot of course as well the next update
released live update 1.2 2.2 on all
plaque
basically that implemented an input
delay on console a 33 millisecond input
delay has been activated on all
offensive moves that being attacks guard
breaks etc and defensive moves have not
been altered that being parried Connor
Connor guard break all that type of [ __ ]
this is the only first step at
compensating for network latency which
is a pretty big issue of course so I'm
glad that they're at least taking some
of the steps forward to do that they
also put in to bug fixes for Centurion
that being sent area will not be able to
lock on to his opponent in an infinite
chain and as well as they fixed an issue
that caused - well time Centurions to
lock their opponent in an infinite chain
together so both of those are not in the
game at this current time thankfully
they're out because that was a nightmare
to deal with the new content of the week
this week is going to be mythic outfits
I told you this was going to be really
nice to look at these are gonna be
costing 15,000 steal each the Viking
alpha is called pledge of Heaven the
Viking alpha is called as guards favor
and the samurai is called tenchu Gumi
I'm pretty sure I butchered that but you
get the point
I'm gonna be showing the rest of the
video that they put on their YouTube
channel so I'll see you guys after the
video is over
[Music]
I don't know about you guys but I
thought those outfits were pretty damn
cool I've seen a lot of youtubers
obviously in the past and still
currently doing videos with their
respective main characters and then
doing it with like a new effect or a new
outfit or any of that type of stuff so I
thought I decided to maybe give that a
try I'll probably later today or
something like that I'll be recording
some gladiator duels or anything like
that with the new outfit and then kind
of try it out and make a video out of it
and if it does well then I'll continue
to do those in the future so definitely
look out for that in the next couple of
hours but continuing on we have a new
event playlist in the event tab and it's
going to be called arena accessing the
event playlist located on your fact--and
stronghold and play the new arena maps
in duel only now this if you don't know
if you do go into the training arena
there's going to be three specific maps
set up for the training arena but
they're also in duel and brawl so now if
you go to the event tab you could play
specifically duel only on only those
three maps which is really nice because
these maps are really well done and hey
you get to seed Albany in the night
version as well that play this place is
going to be available from now until May
2nd so definitely it play those few
matches where you got the chance this is
also going to be a new event order this
week like we usually have it on the
weekend and this is going to be dual
executioner as a community perform as
many executions as you can in duel
matches and the reward will be 2,000
steel and you must participate to get
the 2000 steel and then lastly to end
the video we have on the Warriors then
next week they're gonna be covering some
juicy season 6 info including which
heroes are going to be getting updates
and reworks
the majority of the community has
already been hypothesizing and
theorizing what heroes are going to
beginning reworks but maybe they'll
throw a curveball in who knows hopefully
not because the characters that we are
basically requesting it definitely
needed so they definitely should listen
to us with that as always I'm gonna be
covering this type of recap next week
when the Warriors then is finished I'm
gonna be covering like I said the season
6 info with the updates and rework so
definitely look out next week for that
video doing it all caught up to date on
who's getting reworks next season but
anyway guys it's going to be the end of
the video today guys hope you guys did
enjoy the video like I said I'm probably
gonna
a video out in the next couple of hours
showing off the new a mythic outfit with
gladiator since I do like playing
gladiator a lot hopefully you guys will
enjoy that video so definitely keep an
eye out and then ask a couple hours when
I get the chance to do it as well as the
video coming next week with the season 6
reworks and updates whatever those
characters happen to be and any other
information they talk about next week
but as always like the video if you guys
did enjoy it it does help me out
subscribe if you're new I covered the
leaks the info the informational side
the patch notes the news the
informational side of for honor I like
to cover a lot my two most recent videos
are going to be on screen if you guys do
want to check that out highly recommend
you do and with that guys hope if ago
yesterday and peace out thanks for
watching the video